ces dernières années de nouveaux sujets
jusque là assez peu médiatisées ont pris
une place importante dans le débat
public
parmi eux la reconnaissance et
l'acceptation des minorités le respect
des différences ou encore la question du
genre des sujets toujours complexe
preuve en est ils ne veulent pas changer
de sexe et veulent simplement être sans
genre neutre c'est-à-dire ni homme ni
femme dimanche zone interdite sur m6
décidé de consacrer un reportage à ces
français qui ne se sentent ni homme ni
femme et qui ne veulent pas être réduit
à un genre qu'ils soient payants d'heure
fluides ou encore non binaire ses
citoyens suscite la curiosité parfois
l'agressivité dans le reportage dé
téléspectateurs ont par exemple
découvert le parcours de théo un
adolescent de 16 ans qui se compare au
chanteur bill al hassani peut y arriver
en jogging j'arrive en péril votre
portrait celui de fabien 19 ans est
quant à lui se maquiller une pratique
qui est loin d'être comprises et
acceptées de tous je vois pas l'intérêt
d'avoir des codes un garçon c'est comme
ça une fille c'est comme ça il n'y a
aucun intérêt sur les réseaux de nombre
d'internautes se sont étonnés du
traitement de ces sujets ouvre
l'émission étant beaucoup trop dans le
cliché considérant leur orientation
sexuelle comme un phénomène de société
d'autres encore s'interrogent sur des
chiffres avancés par le reportage comme
cette information selon laquelle un
jeune sur cinq se verraient comme non
binaire une émission qui a soulevé une
vive polémique sur les réseaux sociaux
alors le leem inexpliquée de parce que
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir avec la
sexualité exactement on est bien passé
se sont pas des personnes qui veulent
des transgenres qui veulent changer de
sexe ou quoi que ce soit obligé rien à
voir en fait ce sont des personnes qui
ne s'affirme pas comme un genre ils sont
mis à mis fin ce sont juste des êtres
humains qui ont envie de suivre
je pense plus que de respecter ce qu'ils
ont dans le coeur et la façon dont il se
voit à l'intérieur
moi si j'ai des amis qui sont qui sont
comme ça et je trouve que cette émission
et je vais vraiment saluer m6 pour ça il
ya la polémique mais on connaît déjà les
réseaux sociaux maintenant tout le monde
s'offusque de tout et de rien mais ce
sont des êtres qui sont incompris des
êtres qui sont harcelés pour la plupart
et je trouve que cette émission elle
était nécessaire voire salutaire
merci m6 justement on voir revoir cet
extrait où le commentaire fait référence
à un ado sur cinq se considère comme sa
129e ni fille ni garçon
de nombreuses familles sont déjà
confrontés à ce phénomène générationnel
aujourd'hui un jeune sur cinq ne se
reconnaît pas dans les catégories hommes
femmes pour vos ne se sentir ni fille ni
garçon n'est pas un tabou et il exprime
avec leurs mots et leurs apparences ah
oui
22% des 18-30 ans si vous considérez 18
30 ans comme jeune oui c'est un vrai
phénomène de société
je suis assez d'accord avec ludivine y
avait une belle mise en perspective le
la seule partie qui me gêne et un peu
c'est ces ados qui avec les réseaux
sociaux deviennent des stars parce que
ils ont des problèmes d'identité et je
me demande dans quelques années s'il va
en sortir indemne et je trouve que
c'était un tout petit peu complaisant à
ce moment là démission alors magali va
vous répondre que c'est une façon de
s'accepter il existait des banques sur
la radio que sur le cd reçu aujourd'hui
tout est vu avant cette et que tu le
voyais pas aux lettres maintenant tout
est vu tout se voit alors moi j'en
connais des stars de réseaux sociaux qui
sont transgenres ont dit non c'est non
disons bien et dont je vous garantir que
ce sont des personnes qui sont
formidables qui sont équilibrées joueurs
qui ont un discours est hyper positif
gentil multi marche dans la rue ils se
font agresser on va regarder juste à
l'extrait et on va en trouver
camille qui voit la musique pour changer
de prénom regardez avant de rencontrer
la n'a qu'à me fréquenter des hommes et
des femmes
c'est la première fois que camille est
en couple avec une autre personne de
genre neutre
et tout semble plus évident pour elle en
tout cas le genre je le vois comme un
spectre tu vois avec le féminin d'un
côté deux masculins de l'autre moi
j'avais du mal avec le côté
exclusivement féminin qui avait été
assigné au fait que j'étais né avec la
mystérieuse donc assigné femme tu vois
je comprends pas vraiment mais ça me
dépasse un peu soutenu durant son père
doit écrire une lettre pour montrer
qu'ils acceptent la démarche de sa fille
manon ges que désormais elle voulait
s'appelait camille pour être en accord
avec elle même si ce n'est pas une
transformation
car camille ne veut pas changer de sexe
et devenir un garçon j'ai juste peur
pour toi
les gens sont tellement bêtes et
méchants alors premiers mois de faire
attention à toi je ne m'en remettrai pas
si tu arrives et que tu mal surtout dans
les relations intergénérationnelles et
on va retrouver théo alors lui alors lui
c'était oui je sais mais c'est parce que
ça m'a déjà fait chez elle à la maison
donc et on va c'est extrême a pas
arrangé les choses je pense au journal
el teo effectivement pareil il est ni
fille ni garçon
et quand il revient dans sa cité ça se
passe pas forcément très bien regarder
clos a quitté son ancien quartier à six
mois sa mère avait peur pour lui
lui ne voit pas le problème
ce week end il voudrait sortir dans la
rue avec une perruque
une première tu fais attention oh oui
c'est pas lui qui m'en passer les gens
s'ils se rendent compte que c'est un
gars sont maquillés et en plus de ça
avec une perruque sur la tête jean paul
fabé où je sais pas en fait je sais pas
je sais pas l'action des gens fait homme
sam gay ou hétéro
elle a du mal à cerner télévison tu
cries la france d'aujourd'hui
ils étaient des perruques pourquoi
est-ce que tu n'aurais pas le droit mais
des vérités aujourd'hui non mais je me
dis si je dois me rattraper bas sera le
destin les insultes fusent depuis les
fenêtres perd des habitants on voit des
oeufs et du verre
c'est au tabac
au matin il faut beaucoup c'est pas des
verts des oeufs ou des tomates qui vont
atteindre
mais sûr on peut être que choqué par
cette scène mais on moi j'ai été aussi
choqué par le flot de tweets homophobes
qui a eu ensuite suite à la diffusion de
son élève d'emblée rabot m6 parce que si
ce genre de reportage panne et une pour
une société beaucoup plus inclusive pour
la différence c'est déjà un pari gagné
et on va pouvoir mettre une petite
piqûre de rappel parce que twitter qui
couplé n'abrite bizarrement tous qui se
lasse des entraînements twitter vous
fassiez un peu attention les menaces de
mort les remarques homophobes et
antisémites soient là estivale et madame
tout le monde a le droit de faire ce
qu'il veut en fait donc sur une femme
ce que tu veux tu es tout le monde doit
faire ce qu'il veut et ça regarde qui en
fait si ce n'est pour la personne si lui
se sent ça où elles se sentent bien
comme sa balle et c'est long comme les
celeron faut les laisser comme ça en
fait si on voit pas pourquoi on doit
mettre des insultes et leur jetaient du
verre des tomates c'est le problème
c'est les gens c'est les gens qui aiment
s'y d'avoir mis en lumière ce phénomène